es sind die autobahnen der
nahrungsmittelindustrie riesige felder
auf denen immer nur dasselbe wächst
kartoffeln weizen zuckerrüben usw
flächen die wir der natur abgetrotzt
haben und die mit ihren monokulturen und
den vielen dünger der auch noch das
grundwasser verseucht und den pestiziden
schlimmer sind als die vielen
versiegelten flächen die auch noch immer
mehr wert warum das alles so schlimm ist
und was die lösung dafür ist jetzt in
klicks zum science and future in der
spektakulären edition zukunft rowohlt
hier gibt es drei mal pro woche
spannende wissenschafts videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen in der edition
zukunft vor ort beschäftigen wir uns mit
den spannendsten und spektakulärsten
entwicklung die laut der wissenschaft
tatsächlich möglich sind oder uns drohen
und zwar mit themen aus meinem neuen
buch darauf zurück in den weltraum
erschienen im rowohlt verlag und in
diesem buch geht es um unsere zukunft um
realistische szenarien wie sie aussehen
könnten wissenschaftlich begründet wer
also einen blick in die zukunft werfen
möchte der sollte hier auf den link zum
buch unterm klicken und dann kann er in
die zukunft schauen warum sprechen wir
eigentlich immer von landwirtschaft im
grunde ist dieser begriff ziemlich
schief dann wäre fischerei ja auch
meeres wirtschaft oder die produktion
von gütern fabrik wirtschaft eigentlich
geht es nicht um landwirtschaft denn das
land spielt bei der produktion von
gemüse oder fleisch ja nur eine
mittelbare rolle der begriff führt auf
die falsche fährte das unbedingt land im
spiel sein muss wenn nahrungsmittel
produziert werden in der fischerei zum
beispiel gibt es schon viel mehr zuchten
außerhalb der weltmeere als es
alternative anbaumethoden in der
landwirtschaft gibt die eigentlich eine
gemüse frucht oder fleischwirtschaft ist
und vielleicht kommt man mit dieser
vorstellung er auf alternative
anbaumethoden denn die werden dringend
gebraucht und im weltall
da sind sie sogar unverzichtbar da gibt
es einfach kein land ein feld auf dem
geforscht wird und die ergebnisse sind
absolut beeindruckend sie könnten die
versorgung mit lebensmitteln auf der
erde revolutionieren forschungsteams
weltweit arbeiten mit hochdruck daran im
weltall gemüse anzubauen
noch gibt es einige herausforderungen
doch mittlerweile scheint an
ex haus auf dem mars oder mond durchaus
realistisch fest steht wenn wir menschen
auf mond oder mars siedeln wollen
brauchen wir dort auch nahrung entweder
wird sie eingeflogen was unfasslich
teuer wäre oder aber praktischerweise
direkt vor ort kultiviert möglich wurde
das durch ein in sich geschlossenes
gewächshaus das auch im weltraum für
sichere ernten sorgen könnte doch nicht
nur im all sondern auch in klimatisch
ungünstigen regionen der erde würde ein
solches in sich geschlossenes
gewächshaus den anbau von nutzpflanzen
möglich machen und das ist nicht nur
aufgrund der zunehmenden weltbevölkerung
sondern auch wegen des klimawandels eine
idee die fachleute so schnell wie
möglich umsetzen wollen mit dabei ist
unter anderem das deutsche zentrum für
luft und raumfahrt mit dem project i
denn es handelt es sich um ein modell
gewächshaus der zukunft das ein ganzes
jahr lang in der antarktis auf seinen
ernteertrag getestet wurde und zwar mit
erfolg innerhalb eines jahres konnten
insgesamt 117 kilogramm salat 46 kilo
tomaten 67 kilo gurken 19 kilo kohlrabi
15 kilo kräuter und acht kilo radieschen
geerntet werden betrieben wurde das iss
gewächshaus an der sogenannten neumayer
station 3 und zwar unter an taktischen
extrembedingungen dazu der
wissenschaftler daniel schubert die
antarktis mit ihren extremen
klimatischen bedingungen mit bis zu
minus 40 grad bietet ein optimales
testfeld das gewächshaus besteht aus
einem high tech container der eine
anbaufläche von 310 quadratmetern bietet
innen herrschen 21 grad celsius und 65
prozent relative luftfeuchtigkeit die
pflanzen wachsen hier ohne erde
tageslicht und pestizide
das sollte uns ziehen konnte von bremen
aus beobachten was im gewächshaus
passiert kameras und monitore zeigt
nicht nur sauerstoff und kohlendioxid
gehalt an sondern auch die temperaturen
feuchtigkeit computergesteuert wurden
die wurzeln der pflanzen mit einer
nährstofflösung besprüht und zwar alle
fünf minuten zudem bekamen sie extra
portion kohlendioxid und künstliches
licht und all das sorgte dafür dass die
pflanzen schneller wuchsen als unter
normalen bedingungen ähnlich soll das
szenario dann bei einer echten raumfahrt
missionen aussehen von der erde aus
könnte die pflanzen aufzucht bereits
gestartet werden wenn die astronautin
astronauten sich
noch auf den weg machen platz so daniel
schubert vom dlr
wenn die astronauten am mars ankommen
soll das gewächshaus schon in voller
blüte stehen es würde das ist damit
gemeint schon früchte oder gemüse tragen
und hier auf der erde bricht sich dieses
vertical farming immer mehr bahn
das berliner unternehmen in form hat
weltweit rund 1.000 vertikale
gemüsegärten den restaurants und
supermärkten aufgestellt wo kräuter und
gemüse jetzt erst beim kauf geerntet
werden laut infam benötigen sie 95
prozent weniger wasser 75 prozent
weniger dünger 90 prozent weniger co2
brands beim transport und 99 prozent
weniger platz und es werden dort keine
also 100 prozent weniger pestizide
eingesetzt
alles was man braucht ist strom und
künstliches licht so ein inter gemüse
gehabt und steht übrigens auch im
größten lager park für elektroautos in
hilden ingrid wo man prima snacken kann
wenn das elektroauto lädt ich habe mir
das selber angesehen und der betreiber
roland schüren erntet dort jede woche 30
salatköpfe
eine andere methode wird bereits in
klimatisch gemäßigten zonen angewendet
fische sollen helfen gemüse regional und
nachhaltig anzubauen
bei dem sogenannten aquapol ick
verfahren werden gemüseanbau und
fischzucht miteinander verbunden und
zwar wie bei i dss in einem
geschlossenen kreislauf system das ist
nicht nur ressourcen sondern auch
platzsparend in berlin gibt es zb eine
aqua panic farm die barsche und
basilikum produziert eine andere
konzentriert sich auf den afrikanischen
raum wels und salat und gemüse im
nordrhein-westfälischen wuppertal werden
die barsche und tomaten basilikum und
paprika gezüchtet die rede ist von dem
system namens aqua terra ponik aqua
steht hier für aquakultur also für
fischwirtschaft und hydro ponik meint
eigentlich eine nähert freien anbau in
gewächshäusern entscheidend bei diesem
system ist der kreislauf zwischen den
fischen und den pflanzen die
ausscheidungen der tiere dienen tomaten
paprika und so weiter als nährstoffe
heißt also die hinterlassenschaften der
fische landen im wasser und das wiederum
wird als dünger für das gemüse
eingesetzt dazu würde es zunächst durch
filter geleitet die dafür sorgen dass
schwebstoffe entfernt
das gelöste ammonium aus dem fisch brot
wird durch bakterien die sich im wasser
befinden in natürlichen dünger
umgewandelt
mit diesem wasser werden die pflanzen
lange gegossen dann geht das wasser
wieder zurück zu den fischen das ist
nämlich nicht ganz unwichtig wasser wird
auf der erde ja nie verbraucht es dient
als medium um nährstoffe in pflanzen und
tieren zu transportieren in einem
geschlossenen system reicht also immer
die enthaltene menge wasser und wird
nicht verbraucht zudem geschlossenen
kreislauf wird am besten nur futter für
die fische hinzugefügt andere farben
geben allerdings noch dünger in das
wasser und somit wird es nicht zurück
ins aquarium geführt oft steht ein
nachhaltiger und umweltfreundlicher
gedanke hinter dem ganzen auf gentechnik
und antibiotika wird größtenteils
verzichtet weil der auswahl des
saatgutes ist vieles möglich salate
tomaten und paprika aber auch melonen
oder auberginen können so wachsen bei
der auswahl der fische muss allerdings
einiges beachtet werden die
süßwasserfische müssen mit nitrat
reichen wasser zurecht kommen und
außerdem warme temperaturen mögen in
frage kommen also beispielsweise welche
oder tropische barsche forellen oder
zander dagegen eher nicht nicht nur die
futter gabe sondern auch der wasserfluss
und der ph und sauerstoffwert in den
tanks in denen die fische leben werden
durch computergesteuerte das prinzip ist
übrigens uralt schon seit rund 1000
jahren werden dem asiatischen raum
karpfen eingesetzt die durch überflutete
reisfelder schwimmen manche bezeichnen
das system aqua panic als die
landwirtschaft der zukunft und da eben
auch ist eigentlich kein land mehr dabei
es ist nahrungs wirtschaft also das
ganze spart nicht nur ressourcen sondern
auch platz und ist damit auch auf
kleinem raum möglich und das system ist
unabhängig vom wetter ein riesiger
vorteil denn der klimawandel sorgt in
vielen regionen dieser erde für dürre
wasserknappheit und trockenheit setzt
unter solch widrigen bedingungen könnte
aqua panic eingesetzt werden die zukunft
der landwirtschaft ist also aller
wahrscheinlichkeit nach nahrungs
wirtschaft und dafür gibt es schon jetzt
zahlreiche ansätze die auch in die
praxis umgesetzt werden und wenn diese
methoden dann weltweit eingesetzt werden
wird auch unser planet durch
landwirtschaft nicht mehr so ausgelaugt
und setzt
das wird nämlich zunehmend zum riesigen
problem und werden jetzt gegen den
ausbau der a 49 protestiert wird was
absolut berechtigt ist dann sollte man
auch bedenken wie schlimm die
landwirtschaft für unseren planeten ist
in verseucht und mit dem insekten
sterben auch das vogelsterben verursacht
wird es muss also dringend dringend
gehandelt werden
dieses und viele andere themen aus
unserer zukunft findet ihr in meinem
neuen buch per aufzug in den weltraum
das gibt es direkt hier hier
oder er geht zur nächsten buchhandlung
und unterstützt den buchhandel in diesen
schweren zeiten also vielen dank dass er
dabei seid und klicks und treu bleibt
bis dann bleibt dran